[Music]
hello guys this is a very exciting video
because we have a potential release date
for the second trailer for spider-man no
way home so let's get straight into the
video so according to a brand new leak
by spider fan says the second no way
home trailer will arrive after october
22nd now this date does actually make
sense because it allows marvel to
promote spider-man no way home before
the eternals premiere which is november
the 5th so you're probably wondering
what will be included in this trailer
and thankfully we actually have some
information on this and guys you do want
to listen to this because i think this
will break the internet even more than
the first trailer did so the main focus
of the trailer will be on the sinister
six and remember guys we still don't
know what the whole cast of the sinister
sex will be in the first trailer we're
only teased and given a glimpse of who
they may be so far we got green goblin
and docked octopus confirmed and then we
were teased with electro and potentially
sandman and then there was a little bit
in the trailer where it looks like it
could have been lizard but you know
we're not sure about that yet but even
so there's still one left who we have no
clue or no clues on who they may be but
this trailer apparently answer all of
the questions we have regarding that
also guys this is the part you probably
wait into here but this trailer will
also feature the first live-action look
at the spider-verse meaning we'll
finally see toby maguire spider-man and
andrew garfield's now this alone will
just break the internet just a little
glimpse of them at the end of the
trailer would just send the whole
internet crazy like we've been wanting
to see them for so long um they're
pretty much confirmed to be in the movie
with all the leagues that have been
going around so it's looking good guys
it looks like we'll finally get our live
action look in the new trailer which i
reckon with release at the end of this
month or early november um spider fan
also says you may get a look at charlie
cox in the trailer who is rumored to
play daredevil but he also said that
they might keep the surprise for the
movie so to wait and see i guess with
all that out of the way it looks like we
won't have to wait too much longer for
the new trailer i know everyone's
waiting for it and i'm excited and the
weight is going to be worth it if this
rumor is true because you know we're
also keen to see the live-action
spider-verse so guys that's about it for
this video do let me know what you want
to see in the trailer and um are you
happy with what this leak is saying will
they satisfy you or are they showing too
much let me know in the comments below
and like the video if you enjoyed and
also subscribe so you don't miss any
future content thanks for watching guys